attention message très important on
entre dans la deuxième semaine de
confinement le corps d'un virus est
partout en europe meetic de l'épidémie
n'est pas encore arrivé donc on doit
encore tous agir meilleur moyen pour
éviter la propagation pour éviter de
saturer encore plus les hôpitaux étant
protéger nos familles on a déjà beaucoup
dit mais c'est important le répéter
c'est rester chez soi c'est pourquoi
tous ensemble on vous demande de rester
chez eux on compte sur vous sauver des
vies restez chez vous restez chez vous
restez chez vous restez à la maison
restée chez restez chez vous restez chez
vous restez chez vous en plus on peut
faire plein d'expérience capillaire très
sympa restez chez vous les amis restés
pour rester chez vous restez chez vous
vous occupez vous faites du sport
ne sortez pas rester chez vous restez
chez vous restez chez vous réfléchirez
rester c'est vrai tu t'es chez vous
pardon mais julian découvrir le café
c'est chez vous restez chez vous restez
chez vous parce que vous restez chez
vous restez chez vous allez rester chez
vous restez chez vous restez chez vous
achetez chez vous restez chez vous
restez chez vous restez chez vous restez
chez vous la miche rester chez vous
reste chevaux théâtre comme on dit en
anglais
restez chez vous restez chez vous fera
rester chez vous restez chez une caste
et chez faut assécher vous restez chez
vous restez chez vous restez chez vous
restez chez vous restez chez vous s'il
vous plaît restez chez vous si vous
restez chez vous restez chez vous restez
chez vous restez chez vous restez chez
vous c'est important dealer de rester
chez eux des bougies pas de chez vous
bande de bâtards restez chez vous sachez
vous restez chez vous restez chez vous à
responsabilité collective restez chez
vous
restez chez vous restez chez vous pas
compliqué quand même rester chez vous
voilà ça c'est une une porte d'entrée et
en faites pas vous ne l'utilisez pas
parce que vous restez ce héros en fait